Current Procedural Terminology, CPT,
is maintained and updated annually
by the American Medical Association
to classify all medical procedures.
And it is required for
virtually all billing and reimbursement.
CPT codes are divided
into three categories.
Category I codes are widely
performed procedures.
And are 5 digits long divided
into sections for anesthesiology,
surgery, radiology, pathology,
laboratory medicine, and medicine.
Category II codes are for
the collection of quality and
performance metrics and are 4 digits.
Category III codes are for new or
experimental procedures and
are also 4 digits.
For each code there are full, medium,
and short names or descriptions,
as you can see here for
flu vaccine, influenza vaccine.
These are used for
different purposes and
provide varied levels
of detail as needed.
Given it's used for billing,
a CPT code may need to provide
details necessary to
determine the proper charge.
Here, we see a series of codes for
a psychiatry visit.
Different codes are used to
indicate the visit length.
The charge would be more for
longer visits.
These codes are used to indicate
how much dead, damaged or
infected tissue has been
removed to promote healing.
Removing more results
in a larger charge.
CPT codes are simple but
given this critical role in billing and
subtleties such as these, selection
of the right code is important and
billing personnel are extensively
trained to code correctly.
Typically, to ensure that the largest,
but hopefully legitimate,
bill is submitted.